color is important everywhere and in
motion pictures and get in thanks Bob
color is important everywhere in motion
pictures and guesswork is not your
friend when on set it is crucial that
the director can view a monitor that
accurately shows what the camera has
captured the Sony try master al OLED
monitors use organic light-emitting
diodes say diodes or diodes diodes well
fix it in post built as a semiconductor
the display allows sharper and more
stable images than the previously used
industry standard CRT monitors
displaying nearly the same color space
used in theatrical exhibition consistent
color from different viewing angles and
accurate detail even in the darkest
shadows makes this OLED a game-changing
display these monitors give filmmakers
the confidence that decisions made on
set will accurately be reproduced in
post-production in recognition of this
technology the Academy presents a
scientific and engineering award to
Ichiro Tsui Massa hirotaka maths
matsuyoshi Tamura and mr. Rossano for
the development of the sony 9b B and E
Series trimester elo l'apicio monitors
gentlemen please come up
thank you for your kind introduction
first of all I direct thank all our
patrons and my colleagues including
myself we are all ordinary individuals
not special not genius but together many
of my qualif developed this monitor
which through passion I believe this
prize is a recognition of that passion
and I accept it on behalf of my
colleagues again thank you to the
members of Academy for this tremendous
honor under special thanks to my boss
Shingo shimazaki until Yoshiko Morioka
thank you very much